beneath the shiny veneer it seems donald
trump's
empire is built on sand outside trump
tower in new york there was
outrage ordinary americans learning they
pay more tax than the president
michael came to protest after losing his
job in the pandemic
it's tough you have to think about what
you're going to eat
it's that scary it's a it's a nightmare
it's an actual night plus i paid more in
taxes
in one year than he paid in 10 years
and he's a billionaire there's something
wrong
joe biden's election campaign has been
quick to jump on this
politically comparing donald trump's 750
dollars in tax
for 2016 to tax paid by other workers
for a nurse working in the midst of a
pandemic it feels
deeply personal it's certainly very
shocking
and frustrating to be quite honest
we're here you know risking our lives
every single day
and at the end of the day we all want to
feel like we're equal
to everyone else donald trump has
dismissed the revelations he's a bad
businessman and tax cheat
as fake news and avoided taking
questions
at his latest briefing the figures
behind this story
are astonishing donald trump has fought
for years to keep his tax returns
under wraps but it seems beneath the
glitz and glamour of his empire and
lifestyle
the self-styled billionaire has been
reporting losses of
tens of millions of dollars while paying
far less
tax than the average american in the
first year of his presidency
and in previous years he paid no tax at
all
many voters minds will be made up
already
but just five weeks from the election
this is terrible timing for the
president
we've been paying more taxes on
unemployment than he's paid
you know as one of the richest people in
the world so it's really upsetting
it's one story after another every day
it's it's this and it's that and that's
just gonna go under the rug like the
other stories and it's just
scandals is just normalized with them so
that's just
another thing that adds on top of his
reputation and it doesn't really change
anything sadly
as both candidates prepare to face each
other in the first
presidential debate this will
undoubtedly give joe biden ammunition
and weaken the image donald trump loves
to present
of a successful businessman and sound
caretaker
of the us economy thank you very much
everybody
thank you sally lockwood sky news new
york